when my friends are struggling I don't
say take your time
when my friends are struggling I say go
on when my friends are crying I say go
on
I live my life by that code
[Music]
leadership and communication expert
author Ted speaker his unconventional
views have made him one of the most
sought after speakers on the planet
there's no one quite like it Simon
how are you doing I'm actually feeling
quite lonely I'm struggling to
communicate or present myself in a way
that people will get who I am feel like
nobody can help you and the first thing
that a lot of us should do is reach out
to a friend and say I'm struggling you
should never cry alone we live in a
world where most people are ill-equipped
on how to be there for a friend who's
struggling the first mistake people make
is they try and fix don't need them to
fix me I just need them to sit in the
mud with me so I don't feel alone when
I'm sitting in the mud the fact that
it's such a loud conversation about
mental health is a spotlight on the fact
that we do not know how to build deep
meaningful relationships but the way I
manage it which is different than most
is I
you know I wish I had these skills 10
years ago is the design of the modern
world making it more difficult for us to
find love and to keep it the problem
with it is is its Grass Is Always
Greener because it's so easy to just go
swiping something's out of balance and I
I'm gonna say this over and over and
over again which is just successful
relationships
ladies and gentlemen I interrupt this
podcast with a very special announcement
um something I've always dreamed of
doing obviously I've had Simon sinek on
the podcast three times now he holds the
record for being the most prolific Diary
of a CEO guest we've ever had
and to celebrate that and also to
celebrate his Brilliance we're doing
something special to raise money for an
incredible cause myself and Simon will
be holding an event in London where you
can come and see both of us in
conversation on stage with audience
engagement and questions Live in Central
London on July the 5th this is a one-off
event something that will probably never
happen again unfortunately because of
the nature of both of our incredible
schedules but
something I'm incredibly excited about
if you want to get a ticket all you've
got to do is put your email address on
the waiting list Below in the
description of this episode tickets will
operate on our first come first serve
basis so put your name on that list and
come and see myself and Simon on stage
in London live for a very interesting
evening of vulnerability discussion and
insights
foreign
[Music]
congratulations you are the direvacia
record holder you've been invited back
more than any other guest and it's not
for it's for a very very good reason
which is that your episodes are always
the most adored that we have in this on
this podcast they are um the two
episodes the conversations we've had are
both in the top 10 of all time on the
show and I always feel after our
conversations end that they could have
gone on longer so here we are thanks for
having me back I enjoy coming my first
question for you today is I know you
know this question is often asked quite
flippantly but I wanna I'd really like
the real answer which is
how are you doing
um
you know I think when somebody says fine
they're lying
and so my instinct is to say I'm fine
um
I am going through uh
I'm going through some ups and downs
um I'm in a period of uh flux which
doesn't which is fine that that
genuinely is good
um I like a little bit of Chaos in my
life it's where creativity comes from
and if I look back at my career you know
I would take a job I'd have a
fast-moving career it'd get to a great
point it would plateau and then I'd quit
and I'm sort of at that point you know I
love a steep learning curve I love a
difficult situation and I like trying
something new and building something and
um so there's I'm I'm shifting away from
in-person public speaking which I think
surprises a lot of people
um but recognize that I never considered
myself a public speaker in the first
place it's just something I did to
advance my cause it was never my chosen
career so not doing it as much as I
enjoy it and I know uh is is not that
difficult so what next is
a little bit of an unknown I have some
ideas and I'm testing some things out
but I don't actually know where I'm
gonna go why are you shifting away from
public speaking give me the context as
to why this is a sort of a pivotal
moment
um there are multiple reasons
um you know I I consider myself a
preacher and when I set out on my
journey many years ago I was espousing a
vision of what business could look like
and what the world could look like what
our careers could look like that was
different than the world that we lived
in you know talking about purpose at
work
with some hippie to be stuff you know
and now it's a completely normal
conversation and I'm really proud to
have been a part of that movement and so
when I would stand on a stage I was
preaching to people who had never heard
of my my work who had never heard of
these Concepts at least not explain the
way I explained them and and I was
converting audiences you know that was
and the good news is the movement is is
of is has its own momentum and
um I don't know how many I'm converting
vastly fewer people now
when I walk into the room now they're
looking for tools now they're looking
for you know which is great
um and so I want to now pivot myself so
that I can start having significant
impact again so that I can start
affecting greater change not not just
maintenance not just reinforcing not
just affirming
change impact is what I'm looking at so
that's a huge part
um covid in some respects was a gift it
created a Marketplace for online
and so you know I can do things that I
could never do before which is I can be
in Chicago in the morning and Kuala
Lumpur in the evening that that was
impossible before
um I have the energy to give to more
people
um so I'm doing that which is great
um and at the end of the day
um I I'm I want to learn I want to be in
a situation where I'm actually not
familiar where I'm not very comfortable
you know I'm good on the stage now I've
I've honed my craft and I want to be
uncomfortable again right the personal
side is different uh
you know I know that mental health is a
is a is a big and important topic right
now and that conversation with somebody
recently
and I realize I actually don't like the
term Mental Health
you know
um it sounds like a fixed destination it
sounds like you know if you if you don't
have health
like if you're not perfect there's
something wrong with you so any kind of
Divergence or sadness means you're
imperfect right and that's not true and
I think it's an unfair standard to call
it mental health and I think
because at the end of the day like think
about your body when you go to the gym
right
um we call that Fitness
and some days you have good days at the
gym and some days you have bad at the
gym bad days at the gym some days your
body feels amazing you can lift huge
weight and someday for whatever reason
you got enough sleep you ate you're
eating well you're hydrated you just
your body's just not working that day
and we're all familiar with that and it
doesn't really bother us you're like a
bad day today and you move on and you
allow that to happen but we don't treat
our our mental Fitness the same way you
know being a human you are 100 mentally
fit if you have sadness and if you have
joy and if you have doubt and
uncertainty and insecurity that that's
what it is to be human like your body
sometimes has pain there's nothing wrong
with your body
and so I I like to call it mental
Fitness rather than mental health right
I'm always working on my mental Fitness
and I allow for periods of Darkness
so right now when you said how are you
the space that I'm sitting in is I'm
actually feeling quite lonely
and uh and I learned about how to manage
mental Fitness during covid more than I
ever had prior because we had to deal
with so much [__] right and so prior I
would have been embarrassed by saying
I'm feeling lonely I would have
um hided it or suppressed it don't like
negative feelings
um
uh whereas now I'm just sitting in it
not worried about it
um I'm allowing it to go through me like
I'm allowing myself to have a bad day at
the gym
and
weirdly even though it's not necessarily
fun
um weirdly appreciative of it
um because it makes me human
it just reminds me of a story
um
earlier on in my career I was invited to
speak at an event which is the
association of Meeting Planners so
there's an American Meeting Planners
Association whatever it is literally
everybody who hires speakers from every
big company and Association has their
own Association and they come and have
their own event so to get higher to get
invited to speak at this event is like
if you nail it your career is set for
the rest of your life and if you blow it
your career is over right because like
literally everybody who hires all the
speakers for all the big events is in
this room
and I got invited huge honor right
and I'm this back in the start with why
days and I'm good at start with why like
I've done this thing probably thousands
of times I know my stuff so I get up
there I'm doing start with why
and I lose my train of thought
it's okay
I'm a professional I know how to deal
with losing your train of thought you go
quiet
relax you get your thoughts back and you
pick up where you left off it's happened
before
no problem so I do what I I know how to
do I go quiet
and nothing comes in and now the Panic
starts
now the heart starts pounding now my
life is flashing before my eyes now I'm
recognizing oh my God my career is over
you know and I look at my my pad and I
look at the audience I cannot I cannot
remember what I was saying I don't know
what to say next I don't have a joke
I've got nothing I just got panic
so I turn to the audience
and I say
do you ever have that feeling
that sinking feeling when you lose your
train of thought where your heart starts
pounding and your hands get clammy and
your life flashes before your eyes I
said I'm having that right now and I'll
tell you
I am so grateful for that feeling right
now because it makes me feel alive and
the audience exploded with Applause I
said right now if somebody could please
just tell me what I was saying so I
could pick up where I left off and
somebody screamed something out and went
thank you and I picked up and I finished
the point was
I could have I could have suppressed the
panic but I was open about the way I was
feeling and what I learned was everybody
was there to support me because I had I
acknowledge that I'm human and it's
relatable and so that's how I feel right
now I'm more open about being in a
darker space in the shadows right now
because because it makes me feel it
makes me feel quite frankly normal it
makes me feel human and it's part of
mental Fitness you know and and if I
didn't have off days or off weeks then
how would I know what to work on you
know how would I know what good good
looks like how would I know how to
appreciate the Happy Days if I didn't
have some days that were down so I'm I'm
I'm weirdly grateful for what I'm going
through right now
I
very long answer to you very much
absolutely perfect obviously we always
do long answers here as you know but I I
am the context is incredibly important
and the subject matter is even more
important I know this because I've done
a few talks over the last couple of
years or whatever and when I talk about
the subject matter of loneliness what
will happen afterwards is I will have a
young man who will come up to me you
know when people are asking questions
afterwards when you're taking pictures
or whatever and he'll get very very
close
because he's scared of anybody hearing
him on his right and his left and I
remember I have this visual in my head
of it happening recently and he'll
whisper to me a message of thanks for
talking about my own loneliness in my
life yeah but also asking for some kind
of path through the jungle of loneliness
some kind of solution and then when I
look at the statistics around loneliness
in the UK and in the US it's absolutely
incredible I've often cited that
Theresa May was the first Prime Minister
in our country to appoint a loneliness
czar
for the country
um I think the the statistic which I've
often quoted is that the medium American
used to say they had three people they
could turn to in a time of Crisis and
now that answer is zero and we and we're
heading in that direction at a very sort
of
um Global often Western World level so I
think the subject matter of loneliness
is incredibly important one my first
question on that on that topic then is
what is the symptom of loneliness how
does one know if they are lonely and
because it's so easy to confuse it with
another feeling yeah what's you what's
your sort of symptoms so
when I when I say I feel lonely and I
think when people say they feel lonely I
think what it is is that you know we're
social animals who want to feel
um included but also feel like
um people see hear and understand us and
I think my symptoms of of loneliness are
feeling misunderstood
or like people don't get me or or worse
I'm struggling to communicate or present
myself in a way that people will get who
I am
you've heard me say this you know
there's an entire section in the
Bookshop called self-help and there's no
section on the Bookshop called help
others and what we're desperately
needing more than anything is is a help
others industry like we do not teach
people how to help each other we we do
podcasts and write books about how you
know how you can find love and how you
can build your business and how you can
become a millionaire and you know how
you can find the job that you love it's
all about me me me me me and there's not
enough about how can you help somebody
else find love how can you else how can
you help somebody else you know find
commercial success or we don't do that
we don't teach it and those are the
skills that are desperately needed for
each of us to find mental Fitness
because we can't do it alone you know
when you find Darkness you you whatever
however you want to Define your Darkness
you know you feel alone you feel like
nobody can help you you feel like you
have no agency you feel like a lack of
control and the first thing that a lot
of us should do is reach out to a friend
and say I'm struggling or I need help or
I'm lonely or I'm depressed or I'm sad
whatever your whatever the feeling is
and that person do your friends do your
colleagues do your teachers
have the skills to know how to hold
space so the first mistake people make
is they try and fix
don't try and fix it's not it's not a
fixing thing you know
um it's like I had a bad day at the gym
nothing to fix
you know nothing to fix
um but then do you know how to listen do
you know how to hold space
um and and and I think one of the
reasons more of us are struggling with
mental Fitness is because we ourselves
lack the skills to help our friends who
are struggling with mental Fitness and
the more that we as a society are
equipped to help each other the more
that there are other people there to
help us so you know if if and I have a
rule with my friends
um my rule is no crying alone
my close friends all know this and we
all obey it like I'll get a call from
somebody who's a somebody who's a
significant person in the world that
people know who they are and they'll
call me and say and do you have a minute
and I'll be like yeah what's what's up
there like I just I think I need to cry
I'm like go
what's on your mind and they'll tell me
what's on their mind and they will cry
and that's my rule my rule with my
friends is no crying alone because if
you're at the point of absolute
frustration exhaustion whatever it is
that you you can't hold it in I'd rather
you call me or one of us
and you do it with somebody you should
never cry alone
and and so
I'm really good when I'm in a place like
this of calling somebody and telling
them because I don't want to go through
this alone
and some of my friends do have they do
have the skills where they can say how
do you feel oh this is how I feel that
must be really frustrating yeah it's
really hard tell me more about that well
I'm sort of going through this and that
and they know how to hold space that's
all I need I need to somebody to sit in
the mud with me don't need them to fix
me or clean me off or give me a towel I
just need him to sit in the mud with me
so I don't feel alone when I'm sitting
in the mud
and it's I think it's our responsibility
to be able to have that
skills that skill set to do it for our
friends and the people we love or our
colleagues
um we don't teach listening
we don't teach difficult conversations
the fact that there's so much
conversation about mental health right
now is not is of course in part because
we've just come through this crazy ass
thing called covid and locks downs and
exaggerated politics and you know uh and
divisions in our countries and
etc etc social media sure you can pile
that out if you want but I think really
what it is the fact there's such a loud
conversation about mental health is a
spotlight on the fact that we are we do
not know how to build deep meaningful
relationships I think it is an
indictment
on our current state of affairs that not
only do we not have the skills to be
there for our friends but we're we're
the way we're reacting to it is by
trying to seek resources to help me
rather than teach me how to help my
friends
I think we're going about it half-assed
I was really surprised when you gave the
answer regarding that when I said the
symptoms that that I've indicated to you
that you are feeling lonely
um I think even in my head I was
expecting it to sound more like an
absence of other humans around you and
that's the whole distinction between
being alone and being lonely your answer
was about how you
you feel like you're not understood by
who
is this friends or is this the world or
is it
um
the
I'm a middle-aged man
who hasn't been married but not not that
I care about marriage but I haven't even
had like a 10-year relationship
and I'm realizing some of it is
self-inflicted you know I chose a career
path that made me pretty Undateable you
know I was on the road so much it was
difficult to have a relationship but
some of it is also managing the effects
or the the symptoms of ADHD which wasn't
a thing when I was a kid so I couldn't
be diagnosed which I'm glad for quite
frankly because I had to learn to manage
certain things myself which became
strengths as adult as a strength as an
adult so not not bitter about that I
wasn't diagnosed until I was 32. so
pretty much in life you know like and
one of the things that I've and I've
learned how to manage it really well
professionally like I know how to manage
my ADHD in a professional context really
well
I'm only now learning some of the
symptoms how it affects personal
relationships and how I show up in
relationships that I didn't even realize
so my whole life I'd be in relationships
and and women would tell me you're so
hard to read and I was like I'm an open
book what do you mean I'm sorry I'll
tell you anything you want to know you
know like and and what I've learned is
people with ADHD not all of them but
some of them do something called
stonewalling
which is an accident it's not something
conscious where you're telling me
something about your day whatever it is
or about our relationship and I have I'm
I have nothing to add
and so what on my face you see
nothing
and I I would acknowledge I'm like oh
this is a fantastic and wonderful this
is great but I have nothing substantive
to add so I just add nothing
and so the accidental effect is did I
say something wrong did I offend him
does he not agree
and so I know that about myself now so I
can say to somebody if you're not
getting the reaction that you need if
you need any reaction just ask me for a
reaction how does that make you feel is
that okay I'm like oh my God that's
fantastic right and I'll give it to you
um or I'm really blunt and forward with
questions for example I have a friend
she's an entrepreneur she's a
solopreneur she offers services to
people and I think she's priced too low
and I I was having this conversation
with her and she I said what what do you
charge she told me the price and I said
why do you charge that
that's how I ask the question why do you
charge that
and she was telling me about this just a
few about a week ago it was really funny
and in in my mind I that's perfectly
legitimate question in her mind it was
such an aggressive affront like what do
you mean why do I charge that I'm like
you're worth more why do you charge that
you know I said well how should I have
asked that question and I guess normal
people would have said oh my God you're
worth so much more than that why do you
charge that you know
but I don't I'm just like this so I
recognize that in a professional context
it's one thing people can deal with
questions like that delivered like that
in a meeting but in a relationship not
so much
and so like sitting in this space I'm
like going through all of these mistakes
or things that I've done over the course
of years
and I'm a little annoyed by myself
you know now I know you don't want to
live life in a rear view mirror but I
mean I can still take account and I'm
annoyed you know I wish I had these
skills 10 years ago
you know so I'm just sitting in a period
in my life where I just you know I would
have liked to have had some of the
experiences
that I haven't had yet
and you know
my my friends who are in Fix-It mode
they're like but think of it as an
opportunity now you have these skills
and you thank you I know that
but allow me to mourn the past
that's my loneliness I'm just mourning
how many period of the morning I can
mourn loss can't I like if I if I lose a
friend or a loved one you know
allow me to just like mourn and then
I'll move forwards like I'm okay I I
will move forwards but allow me to mourn
loss and and that's all I'm doing is
just allow me to mourn the loss and I'll
be fine just hold space for me come and
sit in the mud with me ask me how I'm
feeling ask me how I'm doing just let me
vent just sit in the mud with me and you
know again I think to your point
I think we just live in a world where
most people are ill-equipped on how to
be there for a friend who's struggling
can you give I learned this term the
other day which I love I learned it from
Lex Friedman can you give the steel man
argument for your friends
that are telling you to
trying to offer advice what in your
morning process and trying to get you to
be more future orientated as in the
steel man argument I mean is can you
give the argument for why they're doing
that and why it's a good thing
emotions are good
it means you're human like I said I
believe in mental Fitness not Mental
Health
you know that it's a like your body you
have to work out you have to eat well
you have to sleep all the time it's not
something you do and then you're done
you know we've used that analogy before
you and I which is which is what the
infinite game is which is it's like it's
like I want to be healthy okay well
you're gonna have to do it for the rest
of your life it's not an event
and our mental health our mental Fitness
is exactly the same which is it's
constant and it's ups and downs and it's
only
um a challenge or or you need to start
involving professionals if you get stuck
you know like if you get stuck in
sadness you cannot get out of it that's
a different that's a different
conversation if you get stuck in
depression and you cannot get out of it
if you get stuck in loneliness and you
cannot get out of it and by the way the
thing that I love about human beings is
we can have multiple conflicting
feelings simultaneously I am lonely and
optimistic simultaneously my optimism
you know I'm I'm I'm I pride myself on
my optimism my optimism has not
diminished in the least
optimism doesn't mean I can't sit in a
dark tunnel optimism means that I
believe there's a light at the end of
the tunnel even if that light is far
away I'm I have an undying belief that
the future is bright this this too will
pass right that doesn't mean I enjoy it
it doesn't mean I want to be here and I
can be excited I can hang out with my
friends and I can have an amazing time
with my friends and then go home and
still feel lonely like you can have
simultaneous and conflicting feelings
that's allowed in fact it's it's it's
normal but I I cannot stress I think
that the way that I manage this
differently than most I don't usually
talk about it on podcasts but whatever
um uh but the way I manage it which is
different than most is I I I I don't
wait for the phone to ring
I call a friend and say do you have a
minute can I can I talk and if a friend
is ill-equipped they start fixing
I'll interrupt the conversation so
listen I love you
this is not what I need right now I love
you I love you I'm gonna get off the
phone right now okay because when they
go into Fix-It mode it actually makes me
feel worse sometimes
the friends that are some of the best
equipped people
um are folks in the military
you know
um they know how to manage
[__] better than almost anybody I know
uh I've cried with more people in
uniform than I've ever cried with people
in suits
um and the way that we talk to each
other like I have a friend who's a
general I've known him for a million
years so it's fun been fun to watch his
career he's now a general and when we
say goodbye to each other we say I love
you
and when we get on the phone with each
other if it's been a long Gap he'll say
to me hey man first of all he calls me
brother hey brother right which means
something
hey brother I really miss you and he
says things that a lot of guys don't say
to each other
you know
um he talks to me like sometimes I talk
to my female friends there's it's full
of emotion it's full of honesty and
there's no machismo whatsoever and yet
he's a warrior he's a combat veteran you
know
um and he'll say hey man I miss you it's
been a while I go yeah I miss you too
and then we'll get off the phone he'll
say hey I love you I love you too I'll
talk to you soon and
um
though he will I would I mean he and
there's a small group like him
um you know I would call him in my most
uh in my darkest times and I know he
would call me
um
um I have another friend and he's going
through some [__] and I'm honored that
when I called him and said hey I've been
talking about what you've been going
through
you know I just realized I haven't
talked to him in a while and hey what
have you been going through and he just
let it all out I could hear the
frustration I could hear the pain
and I didn't try and fix it I just
encouraged him to keep talking what else
go on tell me more what else oh my God
that must that's really go on yeah what
else and just sat in the mud with him
and it was an it was an honor I'll tell
you it was an honor that he felt
comfortable enough
to do that because I guarantee it he
like so many are really good at hiding
it Faking It suppressing it he's a pro
in fact I'm sure he is where he is
partially because he's a pro
and
you know if you have the skill set to
hold space for someone you will have an
amazing sense
of gratitude
that your friends
trusted you and loved you enough that
they would go there
in front of you
and I think that's a standard that we
should strive for
like I said we're also preoccupied with
ourselves you know
um
there's no
greater honor
there's no great honor than being able
to serve a friend in need
when I see you know a friend sees you
sat in the mud a friend sees me sat in
the mud
that
ill-informed love reaction is to try and
get me out the murder right of course
well-intentioned I don't knock it I know
it's well intentioned how do I get out
the Madam the reason I asked that
question is because I know there's
someone listening to this right now who
is sat in the mud
in many respects in my life I'm sat in
the mud
um
the the thing we're all looking for is
we want
empathy in the fact that we're sat in
the mud of course but we're desperate
for a way out of the mud right that's
understandable
where do where does the plan come from
where does how do we get out of the mud
so I
if it were a prescription you and I
wouldn't have to work anymore
um uh on the subject matter of
loneliness because it's easier to focus
on right so I I
think in large part like any Cooperative
effort like any relationship and a
friendship is a relationship right
um uh having colleagues is a
relationship
in some part it's it's it's it's it's
um co-created right
you know you want to show up in any kind
of relationship professional or personal
and make it a co-creation
and you know I think when somebody first
calls you I I don't think they're
looking for
Solutions they're looking for
companionship and and catharsis
they're just looking not to feel like
overwhelmed
and at some point
um
you can either ask can I offer some
pointers you're not ready for that yet
no I'm not ready for that yet
versus yeah yeah go ahead
or
the person will ask themselves you know
what do you think is what do you think
how do I like what do I do
you know or I'll know what to do but I
don't want to do it like I know what to
do I just need to do this and the person
can just say I'll do it with you and
just offer again companionship most of
us
believe it or not have more
knowledge about how to get out of it
than we think because we've dispensed
the advice in the past
probably you know I think most of us
have a sense like
it's again I think part of part of it is
is allowing ourselves to feel the feels
you know I think if I suppress the
feelings they would last longer but
allowing myself to feel the feels I know
is part of the solution
you know it's
like if you try and suppress feelings
it makes it just it's not good yeah you
know what I mean the signals right
there's signals they're just that's all
they are and and maybe they're telling
you other things like maybe it's maybe
all of my lilians is telling me it's
like Simon you idiot just get some sleep
maybe that's all it's telling me maybe
I'm feeling lonely is because I'm just
freaking exhausted
turns out I've been sleeping better and
turns out I feel better you know maybe
I've been eating crap
you know maybe I'm full of freaking
sugar and fat the social expectations
play well I am this age and I should be
this by now
oh
um
I think I think that I think we we have
to say yes right and like
the midlife crisis is a known thing
and you sort of expect you know you hit
middle life and you're like all right
you're gonna start evaluating everything
you know you're receding hairline your
sagging body you know you're in a new
comedian's joke about it we joke about
it but I I think the new thing is the
quarter life crisis
you know the number of friends that I
have that are in their mid-20s or or
like barely pushing 30 and they're
suffering all the things that somebody
in their midlife would suffer and their
evaluation is different it's not like oh
my God I'm closer to the day I'm gonna
die than the day I was born
it's not that it's more like oh my God
I'm at this age and I haven't achieved
all the things I said I was going to
achieve or I'm just getting started or
I'm and and they and I and I think now
the quarter life crisis is like a real
thing yeah and unfortunately older
Generations scuff at it you know but I
think it's based that is very much
societal expectation like I'm supposed
to be here like the number of young
people I know who I say your entry level
don't worry if you're running the place
yet just even if this is a bad job if
it's toxic get out but there's very few
jobs that are super toxic you know if
you just have a bad boss
like stick with this and learn like the
learning you're gonna get from a bet
like my first boss was a bad boss and I
was there for a year and a half and it
was one of the best educations I got and
by the way the camaraderie that I built
my team because we all shared the same
bad boss was amazing right so I learned
teamwork I learned having each other's
back I learned people taking care of
each other we learned how to manage and
how not to do things
I didn't just abandon it because my boss
was bad my point is is when I say stuff
like that to young people they
immediately interpret that as the worst
advice ever because I'm wasting time
or take a gap year I can't I'm wasting
time like wasting time from what like
what race are you who are you comparing
yourself to what standard like you know
I won't achieve the thing by by what
like what imaginary
scale are we working on here you know
but there is this very
clear imaginary scale by which younger
people young people are
pegging their life against and the only
thing I can offer is my own is my own
experience and I know it's the worst
thing to do because you know when you're
in it you're in it nobody can think that
far ahead but I and it's fun to think
about right because I remember
when I was young in my career and things
were just starting to move though this
one guy I used to go to for advice who's
very much more successful than me
um really buttoned up really sort of you
know operations oriented and he would
constantly give me advice
that either he was basically either
telling me I was an idiot or made me
feel like an idiot by all the things I
wasn't doing or wasn't doing right or
should be doing or could be doing but it
never felt right to me
and he would say stupid things to me
like I won't get out of bed for you know
x amount of thousands of dollars I'm
like
well I do stuff for free all the time
you know and
and
if I didn't have my sense of purpose and
cause if I didn't have my North Star
my why my my vision to guide me I would
have listened to him
and it would have been to my detriment
um uh because
he was very finite minded and it was
very sort of like hit this target hit
this Target and thank goodness I ignored
all the advice and Flash Forward my
career has completely eclipsed his
it just took longer
um and that's the point is the point is
is that the reason people don't follow
my
my ideas the people the reason people
reject my books is because they want my
my advice or they want my perspective to
work this year
and and I and you've and you'll heard
I've used this analogy all the time like
I will tell you how to get into shape I
will tell you have to exercise 20
minutes a day every day you have to eat
healthy and you can have you can only
have sugar in days that start with s
you know I I like what Mark Hyman says
which is you know treat Sugar like a
recreational drug you know
and if you do these things 100 you will
be in shape and you'll be healthy 100
nobody wants that book right but the
problem is you have to do it and well
somebody will say Well when will I be in
shape and the answer is I don't know a
hundred percent it works I don't know
when
and when I discovered
the why
and I first articulated the Y and this
is also important it wasn't just the why
I also discovered
um uh Emmett Rogers work on the law of
diffusion of Innovations which I did
write about also and start with why the
that combination of starting with y and
following the law of diffusion I
realized that a hundred percent it was
going to work by starting with why I was
going to attract early adopters and
early adopters would make the Tipping
Point I didn't know when I just knew it
would work and I just stuck with it
and I and I disconnected myself
from any arbitrary
time-based
achievement
which freaks people out especially if
you're on a quarterly or annual
Financial schedule
but I disconnected I knew it would work
and I just stuck with it turns out it
worked some of it worked quicker than I
expected some of it works slower than I
expected
but it worked and young people
myself included when I was their age I
I'm not saying I had some like I was 100
the same it had to be a discovery for me
and that Discovery didn't come to my
early 30s so my 20s were me being that
person going you're an idiot I can't
waste time but there's something magical
about being on the path and just
sticking just sticking just being
disciplined and just sticking to and the
funny thing is as we're talking about
this I don't even I don't think of
myself as a disciplined person I'm
actually very undisciplined like I'm I
don't have an exercise regime like like
I go in and out sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't and I'm just not a
very disciplined person and I have so
much I have so much respect for people
who are super disciplined when they
commit themselves to something they do
it and they're just really good at
sticking to the plan I'm useless at
sticking to the plan right
and but I'm realizing now the only
discipline I had
was I trusted in these two theories
starting with why and law of diffusion
so apply that to the topic of
someone who is let's say 35 years old
yeah 36 years old 37 years old yeah and
they are
they're lonely yeah
I can't tell you how many friends I've
got and how many conversations I have to
the point that I'm I was considering
writing a book and going on the process
of research who are saying to me right
now that they are single they are lonely
um their biological clock is ticking
um and they and the pressure of them
trying to find someone is so intense
that it's causing them to maybe become
less capable of finding someone yeah so
I'm trying to figure out what what those
people that are listening need
to help them get out of that look there
are people who are better equipped to
answer these questions than me
um but you know I can wax philosophical
like so many things you know and I'll
use another military analogy right which
is
these wonderful human beings who
volunteer to wear that uniform
are willing many of them are willing to
risk their lives to save the life of
someone they don't even like
but they love
right or they Trust
and what people neglect or forget is
that that deep intense trust that they
have for each other does not show up
when they arrive on the battlefield
they've been building it
and the and the and the organizations
for whom they work
know how to build that trust that the
trust exists by the time they get into
combat and this is when I talk about
command and control you know like I talk
about asking people and getting feedback
and all these things but the reality is
is command control also is a real thing
so you know if you're a marine and you
show up in combat they talk about that
as managing chaos that's they they refer
to combat as managing chaos sounds a lot
like an entrepreneurial venture that is
managing chaos right and there are times
where you have to be command and control
but the problem is is you can't be
command and control before you've earned
somebody's trust so the you when you're
back at home you're building trust
building trust building trust building
trust building trust so that when we are
in chaos and I yell and order at you I
don't have time to ask you your feelings
I don't want your feedback I don't need
your ideas I need you to do as I'm
telling you right now and you have to
trust that I'm making the best decision
that I can I'm not going to put your
life recklessly at risk and I even may
make a mistake and people will die
because of my mistakes my mistakes and
that's still okay
but you can't do command and control all
the time it's episodic and it's earned
and so when when kovitz struck and we
first went into lockdown I went into
command and control I even made an
announcement to my team like Hey listen
I know we have a culture where there's a
lot of feedback and if you're not if
those feelings hurt like we we have that
mechanism and I want to hear all that
stuff but I can't hear it for another
two weeks save it up if I'm if I'm a bit
of a if I'm a bit blunt in a meeting
tell me in two weeks I just I don't have
the bandwidth right now because what
we're doing is survival and it worked
fine that came out in control because I
built up the trust it worked fine
the problem is leaders who believe they
can be in command and control all the
time right so what so the reason I'm
telling you this is you're asking two
different questions one which is more
difficult which is we need to build
these skills when we're healthy
and in a good state of mind so that when
we're in the mud we ourselves have some
equipment and some tools and our friends
that we're going to call have some
equipment and some tools right you're
asking with no equipment and no tools
and I'm sitting in mud how do I get out
that is an entirely different
conversation that I'm probably the least
equipped to answer there are
professionals who are much better
equipped to answer that and what I'm
saying is is is
um uh
for so that we don't find ourselves in
that situation
right now with big smiles on our face
how's your day great I'm great things
are great
when are you taking that listening class
um
when are you going to practice
mindfulness and meditation
and have you have you tried meditation
yeah okay yeah
my girlfriend's like a yoga meditation
okay so you're forced to do it yes got
it I have to get away from it right okay
so if for if anyone has ever practiced
meditation you sit still and you focus
on one thing when they say clear your
mind that's not true you don't clear
your mind that's impossible but you do
focus on one thing it could be your
breath it could be your Mantra it could
be a DOT on the wall it could be a sound
it doesn't matter the point is you focus
on one thing and when you get distracted
or you have another thought like oh did
I leave the oven on what you do is you
label that a thought and you push it out
of your mind and you say I'll deal with
that later and you go back to focusing
on the one thing
and
there are tremendous benefits to the
self of uh of of being present and and
calm and clear-headed by practicing
meditation but that is not the sole
purpose of meditation just so you can be
present in fact I believe that you are
not present until someone else says you
are
right so the reason you practice
meditation is so that when you're
sitting with a friend and they're
telling you about their good day or
their bad day you were focused on one
thing and one thing only what they're
telling you as opposed to waiting for
your turn to speak
and you may have thoughts and you say
that's a thought I'm going to label that
and deal with that later
and you remain so focused and there's a
bang in the background but your eyes
don't leave your friend because you're
so present at the end of the
conversation they will say to you thank
you for listening they will say thank
you for being present they'll say thank
you I feel heard congratulations you
were present congratulations all that
meditation was worth it now the practice
of meditation though it has benefits to
yourself
the reason to practice meditation is as
a service to others
the the ADHD point that you raised and
you've talked a lot about exactly that
which is
um being able to sit and listen and and
hear
how did you
or because it almost sounded like you'd
self-diagnosed that as being a playing a
part in your your historic relationship
challenges
how do you how do you know
because I you know what I mean because
if you if you make that sort of
self-diagnosis and then you build a plan
around that and it's the wrong
self-diagnosis you know you end up in
another
unfortunate place if that makes sense so
if I'd if I'd self-diagnose myself based
on that experience with my parents
um I could have been aiming at the wrong
target
so it's about this question is about
self-awareness how does how does one
develop the self-awareness is it
feedback I think there's a difference
between
introspection
and awareness
with accountability versus victimization
versus victimhood right
by the sound of it you didn't say my
parents did this to me
no right not useful but that's
victimization it's the same it's the
same thing right I can't have a
relationship because my parents [__]
me yeah because they didn't give me an
effective model and they didn't love me
enough and they didn't hug me enough and
so the reason I can't have relationships
is because of my parents disempowering
it's disempowering it's also victimhood
right uh whereas
um okay well the cards that I was dealt
um I got a lot of good cards for some
things and in some places meh maybe I
gotta work a little harder on this one
so the cards that I was dealt from
family I hold no grudge I'm not angry at
them they didn't have the tools it's
okay
and um I don't I don't curse them for
they didn't have the tools but um I I'm
gonna have to learn the tools
you know other people learn it from
their parents I'm gonna have to learn it
from other sources
and I could say the same thing about
listening skills you know some parents
are really good at holding space for
their kids
and those kids will learn how to hold
space with their friends because it was
modeled by their parents and some
parents
don't have the tools to hold space for
their kids
or maybe they work in really really
horrible jobs and so they come home and
they're short-tempered and so you know
there's a chain of causation there and
um and the kids aren't learning those
skills they're gonna have to learn from
somewhere else that's why I say we have
to teach it at work we have to teach
these skills at work because we or in
universities because we cannot take for
granted that people are learning these
skills at home or with their friends
what if I just smell though like and I
totally [__] miss the Target and I
just stink like I just like I have
really bad body odor but I thought you
know what what it is is I'm I'm just too
picky so I'm trying to figure out how we
become more self-aware as to what the
real issue is now you it sounded like
you'd spoken to some of your exes or
something also yeah I have great
relationships with many of my exes and
as one ex I have in particular where we
broke up
we'll get back together we broke up
properly
and uh she hated me for a while
uh I probably blamed her for the breakup
I'm sure we blamed each other then at
some point we sort of like calmed down
and we went out for dinner
and we sat at the bar I even remember
the restaurant we sat at the bar
and we literally dissected the
relationship and we didn't do it with
accusation
what we did was we didn't say I we
didn't sit down and say you did this you
did this you did this which is how we
were for the previous you know whatever
six months in our minds we sat down and
said oh my God I'm so sorry I did this I
did this and I did this and sometimes
the other person affirmed yeah you did
that you know but we showed up with
accountability rather than accusation
and at the end of dinner we we hug each
other with immense gratitude because it
is so rare
that you get to sit down with an ex and
take not only take accountability for
the things that you screwed up but learn
about other things you screwed up and
learn about how you were received even
if you thought you're doing things right
and you you know in everything else if
you have a failed business venture you
sit down and you you have a hot wash you
sit down and you sort of like go back
and see what went wrong so you don't
make the same mistakes you do that in
almost every respect of Our Lives
professionally
but very rarely do you ever get the
opportunity personally because usually
the two people don't want to talk to
each other anymore right but we sat and
by the way there was no expectation that
a friendship was going to come out of
this we just sort of like I don't know
why we showed up but we both did and we
would both admit that it was one of the
greatest things we could ever have done
um because we got to find out how we
were in the relationship which usually
you never find out where you are so to
go back to your point I think feedback
is the thing
you know
um you know the only common factor in
all our failed relationships Is Us
you know you could you know you know
it's their fault only lasts for a period
at some point there's some
accountability to be had and if you
don't know what it is there's something
to be said for picking up the phone and
calling an ex
and I don't mean the one that just ended
up like a week ago but like give it a
give it some time like calling an old ex
and say I I know you're probably
surprised to hear from me and by the way
you know it's it's been a long time I
know and the reason I'm calling is
because I'm really taking myself on
and first of all I uh I probably owe you
a bunch of apologies for how I showed up
in the relationship
but I really want to learn how I showed
up are you willing to have a
conversation and just
tell just give me some some point of
view that I don't have do you know if I
did that with my ex right yeah
um I
I don't believe there's anything that
they would say that would surprise me
however I do think they'd say things
that I've never acknowledged
does that make sense
um at my court I think I'd go yeah now
you said it you know what I mean yeah
okay so that's a real so then it'll it
gives you a space look you can't screw
up that relationship it's screwed up
yeah so in that space you'd be like yeah
I did that and you're not risking
anything
even the most introspective people in
the world
don't have total objectivity on
themselves and can't see all the angles
um you don't have to agree with things
that's the thing you know which is just
because somebody says something doesn't
mean that it's true the way the way we
when we do 360 degree uh feedback
sessions when our company for example
the the council we offer is
you you know you have to listen to what
the person is saying the only thing
you're allowed to say in response is
thank you because they're giving you a
gift by giving you this feedback that
they would rather not give you because
it's easier for them not to give it to
you so just say thank you don't argue
don't give excuses don't explain just
say thank you
and you don't have to agree with it you
can ignore it
however we say if you have an emotional
response to it like anger
it's probably true did you have an
emotional response to some of those sure
of course and if you just if you
disagree you just you say you listen to
it and you go no that's not true
right
um
but if you have an emotional response to
something where you start getting
agitated or angry or wanting to defend
yourself that nerve that they touched
hmm
maybe there's a there there I wonder if
you have a thought of an opinion on this
one of the conversations that's the
Jason I probably do you probably do
which is great
um one of the kind of adjacent
conversations that I've often had with
my friends when we're talking about love
and dating I think when we go for dinner
we often have this as well is is it
becoming harder because of the design
and the nature of the modern world for
us to find love and to keep it
because you know once upon a time my
argument might assert that we lived in
villages there was 20 people there I
told a story the other day to my team
that I worked in this call center in
Manchester 20 of us in this call center
many many years ago and first couple of
days in didn't wasn't interested in
anybody I got six months in fell in love
with the girl next to me and I I almost
equate that to like the village we have
a very small contact so it was easier to
find love
is the design of the modern world making
it more difficult do you think for us to
find
love
so I think
well simple answers it's definitely
added a layer of
complication because now love is treated
like shopping you know we shop for
partners like we shop for [__] on Amazon
you know it's like you scroll through
you find one that looks good and you
click like good reviews and you know
good reviews look it's definitely
convenient and it's definitely made life
a lot easier and you never have to deal
with rejection because you don't know if
they swipe left on you you just assume
that they never saw your picture right
like it doesn't actually say rejected
you know
um uh
uh and you I think the problem with it
is is it's Grass Is Always Greener
because it's so easy you know to just go
swiping
uh and you know sometimes you treat it
like Instagram you know I'll I've done
this where I've sat in my bed late at
night because instead of looking at
social media I'm looking at a dating app
and I'm swiping right like I'm clicking
like on a post and then it says you're
connected I'm like ah damn it because I
don't actually want to like go through
the effort of like connecting it was
just I just liking the post you know
um Scott Galloway talks about this uh I
can't remember what the numbers are I
can't remember what the numbers are but
the part the point is there's a massive
disparity of men that just don't ever
connect
um and there's nothing more dangerous in
a modern society than a lonely man
right and if you look at
terrorism and if you look at Mass
homicide and things like that it's very
often a lonely man you know and you add
in Sex and
um uh
and
um
and in cells and you know you know the
Middle East for example you know it's 25
during the height of terrorism you know
a bunch of years ago it was 25
unemployment in the region in a
shame-based society we have young men
living at home and who aren't employed
and they've never had sex because
there's no sex before marriage and how
are you ever going to meet a girl when
you live at home and you don't have a
job and then all of a sudden
that stress comes out somewhere and I
think we don't talk about
sex and sexuality as a part of
our other behaviors I mean I I for some
reason because we we've we think it's
bad to connect you know sex life with
how people show up in the world but you
take somebody who's sexually frustrated
a sexually frustrated man in their mid
to late 20s
um and all of that pressure and
insecurity and you know now desperation
like it comes out in horrible ways and
the the need to exert control comes out
in horrible ways different conversation
Scott Galloway I said you know has some
fantastic numbers on this so I think
um you know the dating apps
uh aren't necessarily
Fair that's one thing you know it's not
like everybody's gonna find somebody but
I do think that there's something wrong
with shopping for people
um and I the thing that I lament about
dating apps that's really and maybe this
is just me
uh because I hate First Dates
um
the worst um but the reason
pre-dating apps or let's not pre-dating
them so it's just when there's no dating
app being used the way that we
traditionally would meet somebody
is you meet them at a party at a dinner
party you meet them at the pub you you
know you bump into them at a museum you
make small talk or you buy them up from
across the room and there's some
attraction and then one of you musters
up the courage to go up and start
flirting and have a conversation and at
some point you say
can I get your number I'd love to I'd
love to continue this and they'll say
yes or no
and the flirting and the initial
trashing has already happened and so the
first date is actually the first date
after the initial attraction and
flirting now with dating apps the
flirting the initial attraction the
attempt to court someone is all
happening simultaneously on the first
date there's a lot there's a lot of
pressure for a first meeting where you
know when you meet somebody in in IRL
it's like
you know
it's happened the initial attraction has
already happened
um there's no expectation that they're
not going to look like their picture
they're going to look like exactly what
they're going to look like when you met
them and it's dinner so they could be
three hours allocated it could be
expensive meals whatever it is
um
I don't I think there's nothing quote
unquote wrong
with online dating I just think we we
like everything
like there's nothing wrong with online
shopping
but there's the reason that bricks and
mortar stores still exist and that
Amazon is opening stores
it's because people like to go shopping
it's a hunter-gatherer thing like
there's entertainment it's more than the
than the purchase it's more than the
transaction it's the browsing we enjoy
you know it's it's in our DNA you know
and and and I think that there's nothing
wrong with online but I think that that
making an effort to do
you know in real life things
should be should be included should be
balanced you know it's like like
everything in the world I'm a great
believer in Balance I don't usually rail
for or against something I'm usually
about talking about balances and
imbalances even social media like much
so much has been said about you know
what I've said about social media and
Millennials Etc I'm not against it I'm
talking about balance and it's out of
balance you know uh you know even
corporate culture you know I'm not
against many of the modern things I'm
against the imbalance you know
capitalism is unbalanced in in its
current form so when we usually feel
discomfort or anger or frustration it's
usually due to the imbalances
um isn't that what where this
conversation started you know that you
know feelings of loneliness something's
out of balance you know and this is why
I call it Fitness rather than health
because Fitness is the attempt to
maintain equilibrium team to find
balance sometimes it tips one way and
sometimes it tips the other way and it's
you're constantly working to maintain
balance that's what all of this stuff is
business is the same you're an
entrepreneur it's feast or famine like
it's never the right amount you know and
you're constantly working on balance and
I think that's why that's the strongest
argument for playing the long game which
is
it's always teetering that means you
have to constantly be alert and
constantly be working because if it tips
too far good
it's gonna tip the other way don't don't
rest on your laurels make make sure you
have got money in the bank like stock
markets just don't go straight up it's
not how it works right at the same time
when it goes the other way it's like
don't worry this too shall pass this
also won't last start working on some
skills that you maybe haven't worked on
start reaching out to people start
apologizing you know if you've been so
self-involved with yourself and now
you're in a lonely Place sometimes being
lonely like is calling up a friend and
saying I've been an [__]
and I am sorry and I'm looking I'm in a
really dark place right now and I'm just
looking back thinking oh my god I've
been so self-involved
that there's no one around me to be
there for and I am so so sorry
you know and again it goes right back to
everything we were talking about which
is it's a color it's accountable for my
it's accountable for me versus victim of
me you know that that I'm not a victim
of the world around me you know
um
what impact does that have on your
self-esteem
the the realization the awareness that
you you are feeling lonely has it had
any impact on your self-esteem at all
does it especially I'm confronting some
of those tough truths from the past it's
a good question you know again I'll go
back to what I said before I'll go back
to what I said before which is um
you can have we can have multiple
feelings at the same time even if those
feelings are opposite so I can be
insecure and confident at the same time
right but so much of it is situational
right I'm not insecure every moment of
every day of course not nobody is but
I'm not confident every moment every day
of course not nobody is and if you're
stuck in one of those things then
there's a problem of like if you really
are overly confident every moment of
every day with no actual self-doubt in
your mind there is something wrong there
there's something there's Divergence
going on there right
um we know this we know that narcissists
are actually filled of self-loathing you
know for all their Bluster and power
they hate themselves right we know this
um and again I think it's all
situational I think it's all and so and
I've I I I've talked about this which is
which is I don't believe in you and I
have talked about this which is I don't
believe in strengths and weaknesses or
right or wrong I believe everything is
contextual so you know people do these
evaluations what are my strengths what
are my weaknesses no what are your
characteristics and what are your
attributes and then once you know those
things you have to know in what contexts
those characteristics or attributes or
advantages and in what contexts those
attributes are disadvantages and work
very hard to put yourself in context
where you're going to be working to your
strengths so if you have a natural
capacity for maths right you're just
really you're just really good like
people say outnumbers and you just add
them up in your head immediately you
don't have to pull out your fingers
right you're just good at it right put
yourself in a situation where that's an
advantage if if you are maths like
incapable
don't become an accountant no matter how
many people tell you it's a good thing
to become an accountant right it's just
not going to go well for you
so you can go down the list of our
personal attributes and I have
attributes
um where for example
I think out loud is that a strength or a
weakness
context context dependent right put me
on a stage ask me a question let me wax
all this other level give me a podcast
on the microphone give me one question
and four hours later you know I'm still
talking you know
Advantage right
sit me down on a team when I'm having a
team meeting and somebody says something
and I'm thinking out loud I'm now
dominating the meeting hmm maybe I need
to learn how to
scale that back a little bit in the
Diary of a CEO we have hundreds of
questions that have been left by our
guests and we've put them
on these cards
and on these cards you have the question
that's been left in the diver CEO the
name of the person who wrote the
question and if you turn it over there's
a QR code if you scan that code you can
see which guest answered the question
and watch the video of them answering it
every time I've done this podcast and
every time we've asked the kind of
questions we ask here I feel a
tremendous sense of affinity to the
guest and our aim with these cards is
that you can create that sense of
connection through vulnerability at home
with the people you love the most and I
have some good news for you as of today
you can add your name to the waiting
list to be the first in line to get your
own set of conversation cards at the
conversationcards.com that is the
conversationcards.com over the last
couple of how long maybe four months
I've been changing my diet shall I say
many of you have really been paying
attention to this podcast will know why
I've sat here with some incredible
Health experts and one of the things
that's really come through for me which
has caused a big change in my life is
the need for us to have these superfoods
these green Foods these vegetables and
then a company I love so much and a
company I'm an investor in and then a
company that sponsors this podcast and
I'm on the board of recently announced a
new product which absolutely spoke to
exactly where I was in my life and that
is huel and they announced Daily Greens
Daily Greens is a product that contains
91 superfoods nutrients and plant-based
ingredients which helps me meet that
dietary requirement with the convenience
that hewell always offers unfortunately
it's only currently available in the US
but I hope
I pray that it'll be with you guys in
the UK too so if you're in the US check
it out it's an incredible product I've
been having it here in La for the last
couple of weeks and it's a game changer
what are those layers that you've peeled
off recently I can think of layers that
I've peeled off in the last you know
couple of months with with people close
to me that I was always scared to peel
off before but I've had to in order like
what
um so with my girlfriend I you know I
reflect and I go I don't think I ever
told her truly that I'd ever had like a
bad day or that I was like feeling bad
about anything I think I'd always just
had this wall up I thought because part
of me stupidly thought that if I tell
her when I'm having a bad day or I'm
feeling anxious or whatever then she'll
start talking about it and it'll make me
more anxious and then I'll have to calm
her down so I just give it to myself and
then in the last you know in the last
three to six months when I felt anxious
yep I've told I slowly ran the
experiment of what happens if I just
tell her about a little bit of it yeah
that experiment went well so I told her
about a little bit more and to the point
now where I've told her completely how
I'm feeling yeah even on my best and
worst days
um
and I would never have done that before
because it made me feel weak yep it made
me feel like I was like not the tough
masculine boyfriend that she would be
attracted to obviously and I have to say
this surprisingly it's caused deeper
connection of course and deeper
understanding which is exactly what I
needed I needed understanding
I needed and I also created a space
where we could say listen when I'm
feeling like this this is how I'd love
you to to respond which often is just
like just just listen just sit in the
mud with me yeah exactly don't don't
necessarily say anything don't try you
know your point about fixing it my
girlfriend she's so through all of her
love and I'm the same with her and I'm
just the same with everybody I always
try and fix yeah it meant men are worse
than women it comes when it comes to
fixing uh my I've been on the receiving
end of that I dated somebody who if I
asked her how are you great was the only
answer she ever gave me that's all I've
ever said to people and uh and it
actually made it very difficult for me
to get close to her because I knew that
she was having bad days I could tell
when she was frustrated and she and so
when somebody puts on that brave face
and always wants to be great for their
partner it's the most selfish thing you
can do because you're denying them that
awesome Joy of being able to be there
for you remember as social animals we
want to take care of the people we love
and how dare you how dare you deny them
that the unbelievable honor of getting
to sit in the mud with you
you know it is it is a joy that human
beings get to experience and one of the
things if you can by the way the biology
proves it that one of the things that
releases oxytocin which is that feeling
of love and connection and trust is
shared struggle
shared struggle releases oxytocin which
is why when families go through tragedy
they get closer which is why since when
societies go through hurricanes there's
intense you know politics get put aside
and we support each other right and it's
the same in a relationship which is if
you allow someone to sit and struggle
with you it actually deepens the
relationship biologically
um so but what we're talking about is
risk what we're talking about is being
vulnerable making you know and it
requires more courage as you've learned
that actually requires more strength to
say I'm anxious today than it does to
lie and say everything's great that's
the irony superficially it's stronger
but in reality it's cowardice and by the
way that doesn't make it easy the words
are easy and I've definitely been there
and you've been there
um but I I think that if we like someone
um and it only and I always say
leadership is about going first that's
why we call you leader right doesn't
mean you have the answers it doesn't
mean you're right it just means you
stepped first into the unknown that we
uh took the risk to go first and so in a
relationship one of you can take the
lead
one of you can go first to set the
example of what it looks like and feels
like to say I'm having a bad day today
and I don't need you to fix it
I know what I'm going through I want you
to I want to tell you all of this stuff
because I want you to be there with me
and I want to be there with you
because I don't want to feel this way
alone and that key Second Step which I I
learned literally in the car this
weekend with my partner was
you then need to work with them to
educate them on and vice versa
on how you would like to be held correct
in that moment correct which is actually
a really difficult thing which is
um for example I'll give you an example
with me my partner when I'm going
through those moments I go really quiet
yep I shut down I'm glued to my phone
and so if she says something to me
I my brain almost viewed it as like why
is she bothering me in my hard moment so
I might say something like babe I'm just
dealing with something
and then it's it always seemed to me
like should ask me more questions of
course hey babe look at this come look
at this look at this I'm just trying I'm
thinking I just told her that yeah I'm
dealing with something she's making it
worse she's trying to give me more stuff
to deal with yeah so I had this
conversation with her I go I said to her
let's let's just create a safe space
here
this is how I feel I feel like when I'm
going through something and I'm dealing
with something and I shut down and look
at my phone the amount of irrelevant
questions you ask me then increase
considerably and then she gave me her
perspective on that situation then we
kind of um formed a deal about in those
moments the first thing I'm doing wrong
is I'm going babe I'm dealing with
something right I'm saying with a
certain tone right and a lack of love
and empathy yeah that's immediately
making her feel abandoned and rejected
of course something I'm doing something
so she said to me if you say it in this
way if you say babe I love you but can I
just have five minutes because
something's something's up I just need
to work through this her reaction would
have been totally different of course
and it and having that second stage of
like let's find a solution together
and understand each other was so
difficult we're going back to my
question well it goes back to what we
said before which is business
Partnerships personal relationships
friendships are acts of co-creation yeah
and so I have definitely been guilty of
checklisting people professionally and
personally
oh they have this they have this they
don't have this
I guess I could do without that one you
know and and the problem with the
checklist is people can feel it
you know
um and I keep complaining this I said I
have a bad picker it's because I would
show up with my checklist early in my in
my in my 20s and you know if they were
strong which is the kind of person I
want to date they would be like this
idiot has his checklist I can't meet
everything on his checklist he's not for
me
right and so what I ended up was
attracting was people who would mold and
bend to fit my checklist and then I'm
like but then I don't even know who you
are uh bad picker my fault right take
full accountability but the point is is
like I go to painting I might have
preferences I have a couple of deal
breakers you know I think everybody
shouldn't know their deal breakers but
the amazing thing is is
we actually I actually have fewer deal
breakers than I thought I did what are
your deal breakers not talking about you
set that up no that's my that's for me
fair enough that's for me this is not a
dating app I can tell you my deal
breakers great I'd love to hear them
uh
uh I mean look there's some obvious ones
right some of my deal breakers you know
I somebody I I want somebody who who
Who's who's who's taking themself on
they're in they're in constant growth
and constant Improvement right somebody
I think they've got it all figured out
this is not going to work out you know
um obviously you know Integrity somebody
who lives a life of service is really
matters to me like when somebody like
all they're driven by is Money Cash Fame
Fortune success you know like anybody
who posts a picture of themselves in a
private jet on a dating app is an
immediate no you know it's like right
like of course those are some Basics
because those are my my values I'm
service oriented and I and I I don't I
and I need to zoom what I need to date
somebody who's passionate about
something it doesn't matter if it's
commercially successful or not that's
not what I care about but you have to
have a love for something a passion
something that like excites you and gets
you out of bed even if you don't get to
do it all the time I don't care if
you're a painter I don't care if you're
trying to change the world it can be big
it can be small just have a love for
something if I give you my three please
so I I was through my early 20s I love
that you wrote them down and you know
them it was there's only three of them
they used to be 300 so it'd be like this
color hair this color height this color
this this I want it to be this shape and
this size and then I was like how do I
consolidate this down so I came down to
three things that's important first one
is quite surprising to some people but
sexual attraction of course because I've
had physical attraction without the
sexual attraction
um but I've never had it almost the
other way around good distinction so
I've had physical traction where I've
dated someone who's absolutely beautiful
and then there wasn't sexual chemistry
though so I prioritized sexual
attraction which I think is important
the next one is intellectually
stimulating intellectually which is what
you've described where they have a
passion I might not even believe it's
true or like it or care but the the fact
that it stimulates me and they can we
can have a conversation they can teach
me yes exactly yeah me and my girlfriend
she believes in all these things I don't
believe in but she'll sit there and tell
me that you know
something with crystals in this glass of
water I don't believe that she has
doesn't have an expectation that I'll
believe it but I'm peering into a new
world of breath work and spirituality
and right I do believe in breath work
anyway
um and the third one is that we
make each other better people really I'm
gonna be honest it was a bit more
selfish it was actually that she makes
me a better person but I'm willing to
give that back obviously and I want to
give that back and what I mean by that
is in my mission in the work that I love
to do they support me so those three
things I think if I can find someone
that has all three
so I think you've you've summed up my
three as well I went way more specific
which is why I rejected the question but
if I take it up a few thousand feet okay
sexual attraction 100 and I think you're
it's a great distinction between
physical attracts and sexual attraction
so I I I I agree with those three those
are my three too the way I used to
describe or I still describe
relationships I think great
relationships are based on what I call
three plus one which is you have to have
uh
and it's the same list that's the funny
thing you have to have uh intellectual
compatibility which is you teach and
learn you have to have emotional
compatibility where you're showing up to
grow together right you can find
vulnerability and hold space for each
other you have to have sexual
compatibility which I consider part of
creativity so creative and sexual which
is not physical attraction it's sexual
attraction and create and like I said
creativity and you can have a good
relationship with one and a half or two
of those but you kind of have a great
relationship without three yes because
they they're not all on high at the same
time they sort of they go up and down
and they they wax away and so you need
the others to hold each other hold the
others up when one is down that's a good
point right yeah that's why you need all
three because like I said you can have a
ton of fun with one or two of them yeah
but great requires all three and the
plus one is circumstances
ah like timing like timing location like
I've met people who are threes
and they're married and their kids and
they're happily married and we look each
other and go at a different time it
might have worked but definitely not now
and we just smile and we go on or I've
met somebody who lives on the other side
of the world and I'm not moving they're
not moving and you're struggling you go
ah circumstances were different and you
know it's like and you just it's not a
it's not a sad thing it's just it's a
smile and it's like I've met I you know
and and by the way
I've dated one and a halfs and twos and
they're amazing people
but they're those three things it's so
true the reason I know that about it's
so funny that my three plus one is yeah
is your three yeah it's exactly the same
list well I've I've dated the only
reason I have those three is because
I've dated someone who had two right and
I've had two so you've heard all the
permutations of two but there's always
been one missing yeah and so I remember
thinking
in the woman that I thought I was going
to marry that was missing this one thing
um if she just had that one thing then I
genuinely believed I would have been
happy and I'm thinking about this
particular person for many years ago
she's married she's got a kid now and
everything I think I'm I am lost out
there but I'm very very more happy
myself but she just missed one of those
things and then I can think of my
previous race like oh if they just had
that one thing so now I found someone
who I genuinely yeah
whether she's listening or not has all
three and I go that's me let's go to the
till yeah I mean like the thing the
thing that I'm appreciating there's two
things I'm appreciating one she has all
three but you have to evolve three for
her I hope so right because
like she has to find you sexually
attractive she has to find you
intellectually stimulated and she has to
make she has to find that you're
emotionally available for her which
means when you're having a bad day you
have to say I'm having a bad day not be
great all the time otherwise you're only
a two to her if you're actively being
strong all the time then you're only a
two to her and you'll only ever so there
you go so it's all fine and good for you
and I to have our our three plus one but
we have to have the three for them too
and that's the work that fluctuation
point is so important Yeah because
sometimes we just we have two in our
relationship yeah two of the three yeah
but the other two are very important to
hold us yep through that and they and
it's unpredictable as to when they go up
and down and sometimes you're not
sexually compatible and you're just
snuggling and that's all you want to do
and you don't want to do anything more
than that but that's okay because the
vulnerability is so deep and
intellectual is so high that it's okay
like it the relationship is really very
very good you're both very happy should
we make this dating app or should we let
someone else steal the idea because
there's gonna be someone out there you
know three plus one I think we should I
think we should make it okay
um and we should call it three plus one
I love that so I guess I do know my list
and that's that's the three and if I
look back at my my failed relationships
and again personal accountability
included you know I think that in some
cases I definitely did not present
myself in one of those things
um or like I said the act of co-creation
is really I'm this is to me is like like
the biggest Insight that I've learned
about myself in my own dating life which
is
which is
and I love what you said which is I'm
not into her crystals and all of that
stuff and she knows it you're not
pretending that you are right and you're
okay with the fact that you know she
wants crystals to guide her life and
she's okay with the fact that you don't
and I think that's really important
which is the number of people I meet who
say well I'm into crystals and he's into
crystals this is gonna work and I'm
thinking Hmm
maybe but or worse they go he's not into
crystals I could never date him
right and it's not a question whether
they're into it or not it's a question
whether they are open to learning from
you
and they're not rolling your uh their
eyes
when you start speaking you know uh or
vice versa
um you know there's I've forgotten his
name there's a famous relationship
therapist who can tell in the first five
minutes if a couple that's come to see
him are gonna survive or not and the
test is when one of them starts talking
and the other one rolls their eyes it's
over professor John gottman is that yeah
I I did a he did a thing with him I did
a thing on him so good right yeah it's a
contempt yeah it's contempt and and what
it is it's not just contempt it's
it's intolerance right like you idiot or
how can you be so stupid or or oh God
you know yeah and I think when somebody
starts talking about their crystals and
you start rolling your eyes it's over if
somebody talks about their crystals and
you can say it's not my thing but
tell me I genuinely want to learn
and I'm open to some of it I want to
learn things I know nothing about I like
my my last girlfriend is so good at the
things she's passionate about she's so
good at it
and she'll send me pictures when she's
working on something of something she's
working on and I just like I'm so blown
away about how good she is at the things
she does I get joy out of seeing her be
so good at her thing you know it's I
love it
um uh do you miss her we're still very
close friends have you experienced
heartbreak
yeah
I have
you mean like yeah yeah romantic
heartbreak yeah sure
I think I mean like I think I've had all
the things
I was I think I posted something the
other day about just how it's the most
incredible incredible feeling no as in
it's not awful yeah but it's an
incredible because it's so deep
prevailing
that I actually think it teaches you a
lot about the nature of what it is to be
a human I think this is a perfect we've
gone in a beautiful Circle here which is
to experience heartbreak though awful
um again it goes back to balance right
in all sadness there is lesson and joy
in all happiness there is
um
um there's a cost
right always there's a cost for
everything good in our lives and there's
less of an opportunity and everything
bad
or negative right so you know all of the
things that I've done that have brought
me tremendous happiness tremendous Joy I
I know some of those costs and it's only
bad if the cost wasn't worth it but in
in most cases the cost was worth it and
I did it with eyes wide open right
um and when there has been pain or
loneliness I'm learning about myself I'm
learning about my friends
um I'm learning about how I want
and need somebody to show up for me
which means that in those good times I
can equip them
and I can be better equipped myself I
can say Hey listen if this ever happens
I know I know what I know how you can
hold space for me you just to say these
three things
I need you to do this and you'll be
amazed how how responsive I can be in
that situation to your point about
learning how to communicate with your
girlfriend you know about when you're
feeling anxious and you need five
minutes to yourself right
and as I I'm gonna say this over and
over and over again which is successful
relationships are acts of co-creation
and to have a successful Act of
co-creation you both have to be really
equipped to listen and and to volunteer
information to help the other person in
other words when we talk about what we
need we're giving somebody tools and
when we learn to listen we're gaining
tools
and the goal is to help them fill up
their toolbox and to work very hard to
fill up your own so filling up your own
is about listening and filling up theirs
is about being an effective communicator
and now when you both have tools you can
go build something together because if
only one of you has tools the thing
you're going to build is going to be
weak
um and a Business Partnership a creative
partnership a personal partnership there
are acts of co-creation and that that
insight has come from failed
relationships
and thank goodness some very strong
smart wonderful women who've told me do
you know what your problem is
and I listened
and I asked you 20 minutes ago what wool
you'd bro you'd pull down I said what
you know the layers of the onion you've
peeled back I shared mine yeah I said
with my girlfriend I've started to tell
her when I'm what I'm really feeling
yeah I've never done that before what
are those walls that you've recently
pulled down so that people can come
inside I've become much better at
understanding how some of my symptoms of
ADHD show up in relationships which I
just was unaware of and so instead of
taking total accountability which I do I
take accountability for showing up I'm
now able to explain them so somebody can
look for them and point them out when
they're happening happening so I can
take accountability because it's about
some of it's about awareness right and
so I literally can say very early in a
relationship you may experience this
with me
dot dot dot if it happens I know that I
do it please just point it out and I
will know I have the tools I'm just
sometimes unaware that it's happening
right and
so I'm asking for co-creation I'm saying
look I'm in this I'll take I take all
the accountability for my own behavior
sometimes I just need you to tell me
when I'm doing it
and so I'm asking for help right
um and like I said leadership is about
very often just going first and if
either person in the relationship goes
first
it gives a safe space for the other
person to say well let me tell you about
me
um uh and I think being open to
feedback allows you to get feedback too
um
but to me the huge Insight that I wish
I'd known before which is even though I
may have said it I didn't know how to do
it the act of co-creation you know I I
whenever I you hear a relationship like
really successful relationships you
always hear both the partners say it's a
lot of work yeah and like I never really
understood that like if it's such a like
I look at my great friendships
I mean I wouldn't say there's a lot of
work you know they flow and but I guess
the difference with the definite the
difference with a friendship is like I
don't have to see them every moment of
every day
and and I think the work
is that act of co-creation I thought the
work was sacrifice when I had great
relationships going oh it's a lot of
work I thought well they're not sleeping
at night and right he can't watch the
football every time he wants to watch it
I didn't think it was active work I
thought it was the stuff that you didn't
get to do that's funny yeah it's not
sacrifice it's service yeah the and and
again
you know it's really funny you know my
experience with the military versus
private sector so if I do anything pro
bono in private sector
and this is since the dawn of time right
if I do anything as a favor to a company
almost always they will continue to take
and take and take and take until I put
my hands up and go okay we're done this
is enough right
the military it's the total opposite
I'll do something as a pro as a favor to
somebody and I will never hear from them
ever again
and the reason they don't call me is for
fear that they will look like they're
taking advantage
and I have to sit down with these people
these wonderful human beings and I found
a way I said Do You Realize
I got a I found a way to get them to
call me which is I'm like do you realize
when you don't call me you deny me the
opportunity to serve my country and that
gets them every time but the reason I
bring it up is it's the same in a
relationship
which is when you don't call me and ask
me for help when you don't call me and
say I need to cry when you don't call a
man sign in the mud you deny me the
opportunity
the joy
the honor
of sitting in the mud with you
not Joy honor you deny me the honor
because it's not always fun you deny me
the honor of sitting in the mud with you
and I remember telling one of my close
friends I said we were riding bikes
somewhere and I just out of the blue I
don't know why it hit me I turned him
and I said you know you're one of those
friends that if I was really in the [__]
I would call you
and his reaction is he didn't say thank
you he said I'd be mad if you didn't
and I've done that to friends
I've done that to friends a friend of
mine who who is struggling I said when
we got off the phone I said Hey listen I
know you're in a bad place so don't be
an [__] and deny me the Joy or deny
me the opportunity to sit in the space
with you moving forwards okay like if
you if you need to call me at the middle
of the night you call me don't deny me
the opportunity to to be there with you
if you've previously handled the moment
when they did call you by being trying
to be a fixer or anything they're just
not going to do it regardless of what
you say so do you know what I'm saying
correct and the reason why I know this
is because I said this to one of my
friends recently who had opened up to me
um he was in he was in he was back in
London and I remember going to say to
him oh man please tell me next time this
happens you know you always seem to tell
me when it's it's and then I reflected
and went you know why you're a fixer I'm
a fixer and so he doesn't want to
[__] call me exactly because because
he doesn't like the way that I exactly I
hold space for him I'm trying to correct
everything correct so even if I'd gone
you [__] better call me next time
yeah he would have in his head go what
you can say now is I realize in the past
I was ill-equipped I didn't have the
tools and how to hold space for you yeah
and I realized in the past when you've
called me I've tried to fix everything
which is hardly an incentive for you to
call me again and I want you to know
I've been working really really really
hard on that skill set so give me
another chance if you're ever in the
[__]
I am better equipped I won't be perfect
it's a work in progress but um I want
you to know that I want to be there for
you and I think you'll be surprised I'm
a lot better than I was and if I'm not
you can tell me
okay
because I would want somebody to tell me
if I if they're in the [__] and I start
going to fixing mode they go Simon
you're trying to fix me go sorry sorry
and I can back off immediately because I
know what's happening
because you can correctly this is the
great thing about human beings is we're
like it's kind of like the difference
between public speaking and writing a
book right public speaking is really
forgiving I can have screwed up grammar
I can misspeak and people are tracking I
can Bounce from subject to subject and
people are fine if I did that in a book
it's unreadable right and so it's the
same having a conversation with someone
like it's a very forgiving process like
when you're trying to fix something and
then you're doing and that's not what
they need and they go stop trying to fix
it you're like sorry sorry you can
actually
get the energy in the right place back
really quickly something you can't do
over text yeah just I had to put that
public service announcement in there
um
um you know they're very easily
correctable it's the nice thing like you
can start I mean we've both had the
experience where you're having a really
bad it's going sideways fast and it is
going towards bad and one of you or both
of you is really making it worse and
pouring you know uh fuel in that fire
and then all it takes is one of you to
back off and say listen I'm this let's
can we just take it back and you and
you'll end the phone call hugging and
you know hugging each other it's all the
time it does
we sit here in a couple of years time
Simon and we we have a conversation and
some of the challenges you're facing in
your personal life some of the ones
you've talked about personal and
professional transition moment in your
professional life
um they are they're in a better place
things are idyllic dare I say because I
think that's a bit of an impossibility
in the human condition but things are
idyllic what does your life look like
um
but
you know for me scale matters
and
I I am looking
so the the one of the things that I I I
measure success by momentum
not by achievement
I think I've shared this with you before
how I've always viewed my careers in
iceberg
which is when I first started when I had
a vision of the world you know I imagine
a world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do that is a vision that no one
else can see it exists in my imagination
it's like an iceberg under the ocean I
know it's there I can see it but no one
else can see it because there's nothing
sticking above the ocean and so I talk
about my vision and people be like
you're an idiot you're an idealist
you're crazy that's impossible and I do
some work whatever it is and a little
bit of Iceberg pops up I've done
something that is a a tangible
demonstration of what I'm talking about
you know gave a talk you know gave some
examples found a company
and somebody goes oh oh I see yes I can
see what you're talking about now and
they start working with me and now those
are the early adopters and I keep doing
work and I keep doing work and the more
and more of the iceberg starts to stick
up above the ocean and no matter how
much no matter what point of my career
I've been in
no matter how much success I've had
however you want to Define it when
somebody says to me oh my God it's
amazing what you've achieved my answer
is always the same
tip of the iceberg because though there
may be more icebergs sticking above the
ocean now than there used to be all I
can see is what remains to be done
beneath the ocean and that is vast and
so I'm never really satisfied with what
I've achieved I'm trying to find ways to
get more of the iceberg out of the ocean
right and so the question is is what
I've been doing up until now will have
some effect to get more Iceberg up but
not not as much as I need so
if if you ask me sort of like what does
my life look like in in in the future I
always think in terms of momentum
and the thing that drives me is all of
the founders of the women's suffrage
movement in the United States all died
of natural causes before the first woman
ever voted
in other words I have to put in place
um as many systems and and elements as I
can so that when my time comes I will
die confident that others will continue
the work that I've been working on my
whole life without me just as I have
continued the work of those who came
before me why does that work matter to
you
I believe we all have a responsibility
to leave this world in better shape than
we found it
the accomplishment of that work how
would it make you feel how does it make
you feel on an ongoing basis I am proud
of the momentum that I'm contributing to
and momentum is more important to me
than any specific thing that I may or
may not have accomplished
you know because why not just go get a
yacht and go to a beach and just like
Live It Up
I mean I would probably enjoy it for a
few weeks and then I'd get bored you
know I like I it's a probably some sort
of neurodivergence I like
I like difficult and uncomfortable
and overwhelmingly huge problems are my
favorite kind
um I you know
and
you know undoing everything Jack Welch
did and getting capitalism rebalanced I
mean I can't do that alone for sure I'm
not the only person who has that Vision
um I'm doing my part and it is so vast
with so many moving parts that is so
complicated that the easier thing would
be to give up and just go live on a
yacht it gives you a sense of meaning oh
don't get me wrong there are days that
that abandoning it and just like it was
very appealing you know but it gives you
a sense of meaning it gives you a sense
of like life becomes worthwhile when
there's something scary I want to know I
I want to know that I lived a life worth
living and for and I and by the way for
different people it that is defined
differently you know for some living a
life worth living means looking at a
child that you've raised and saying that
kid will be okay without me
in other words they will continue the
work that I've done without me it's the
same it's the same it's all the same
mentality
um and and and
I I don't care where somebody finds that
meaning I want them to have it
the reason I ask this is because I'm
always trying to separate like The
Virtue from the from reality and when I
speak to young kids they all want to
change the world and I'm always
compelled by like why and even with this
podcast but if someone asks me Steve why
do you do the podcast of course I can
say you know I want to help people with
this information and whatever else and
I'm always like trying to make sure that
I'm fully in tune with the exact why the
most it like in a human reason why I'm
doing this like why am I doing this am I
doing it because lots of people watch
and that's great for my ego and my
self-esteem or whatever because those
people are clapping I'm doing it because
I see these messages and people come up
to me and say it's really helped them
to be honest it's probably all of these
things from being like truly honest with
myself it's probably all of these things
well they're they're metrics they're
indicators right yeah like you and I you
you and I one of our metrics
it's a hard one to track is there is
tremendous
um
I don't know words to use I think there
is gratitude when somebody comes up to
us on the street
and says thank you so much I read your
book Let's do podcast whatever it is and
it changed my life
right and this is a total stranger who
just by chance that we happen to walk
past them in that moment so we can
safely assume that there are other
people that we haven't walked past but
through and and not only did they see us
they mustered the courage to know but
talk to us you know and
um
and that is that is a metric why does it
feel so good
um it's not about feeling good it's not
about feeling good for me it's it's
proof that the work that I'm doing is
going places I never imagined it would
go and does that feel good uh that feels
like yeah I mean it feels like the work
that I should continue working that's
what it make it what it makes me feel
it's not doesn't make me feel like it's
not like I like it doesn't like do
anything to my ego or anything it just
reminds me you got to keep doing this
like you don't have a choice you know
um I I don't know if I've shared the
story with you before but I went to
Afghanistan uh with the air force during
the war in Afghanistan I went for 24
hours
and nothing went according to plan
and we ended up thinking we were going
to get stuck there and I never told my
parents that I was going to Afghanistan
we landed at 10 o'clock at night in
Bagram air base and uh and the door had
opened on the side of the plane we
hadn't got off the plane yet and about
10 minutes after we landed the base came
in on rocket attack and three rockets
hit 100 yards off our nose
I could you could hear the booms
obviously the air raid sirens are going
the over the speakers it's telling
everybody to go to their shelters and
we're just on a plane filled with gas
and weirdly I was calm because everybody
else was calm and we never bothered
putting on our vests or our helmets
because what's that going to do and
everybody we just sort of hung out and I
was weirdly relaxed and for anybody
who's ever been in a war zone they all
know this
um you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you don't necessarily
have them at the right times my Panic
came later
um we finally were given the all clear
we went to our quarters the next day I
had the most Amaze after about three
hours of sleep that's all we got had the
most amazing experience I got to
experience an airdrop mission where we
flew a C-17 at 2000 feet I watched the
back of the door open and whoosh flew
out the back fuel ammunition and water
supply to Ford operating base you know
about an hour and a half two hours from
Bagram and then we flew back most
amazing experience right now the goal
was to leave the country I was just
there to experience an airdrop meet some
people I had no particular
responsibility other than to witness
um and uh now the goal was to leave the
country great there's nothing regularly
scheduled and so we found another plane
that was going back to Bagram we asked
the pilot can we join your flight he
said yes we waited for many hours
because that there's a lot of waiting
and we finally got on the plane we're
literally five minutes from leaving
we're all strapped into the back of this
kc46 again and it's a outbound era
medical so we're taking out wounded uh
wounded servicemen and women and
um and five minutes before we leave the
pilot comes up to us and says I need to
bump you off this flight because I need
some extra room for stretchers and we
went sounds good if there's ever a good
reason to get bumped off a flight this
is it so we took our stuff off and we
thought okay let's go find another
flight
and that's when we learned that there
are no other flights leaving until
Tuesday and it's only Saturday
and
um
and now all of a sudden every every
fiber in my body sank all of a sudden I
realized I'm stuck in this country and
there's no guarantee I'm gonna get on a
flight on Tuesday I don't have any way
to contact my parents I'm just going to
be completely out of touch after the
date that they think I'm coming home and
even if I did call them what am I going
to say
I'm not going to be home I'm in
Afghanistan like in the middle of a war
you know
every I remember I had I was I had a
tremendous self-awareness of the of how
I felt and who I was becoming
and there was a public affairs officer
who said I can get you to uh Kyrgyzstan
but you don't have the right visa and I
literally put my finger in his face I
don't do that I've never held my finger
in someone's face in my life and I put
my finger in his face and said you get
me on that plane like I don't talk to
people that way and I could see myself
becoming this person that I am not and
didn't want to be
we went back to our quarters we're all
exhausted and so I lay down on the bed
and closed my eyes just because I was
tired but there's no way I was sleeping
my mind was racing
one of the officers said well I'm gonna
see if I can find us another flight so
he left
and the other of us sir said well I'm
gonna go to the gym then and he left and
he thought I was sleeping so as he left
he turned the lights out and I was left
by myself in the dark my mind going
crazy and now I'm panicked that feeling
that I should have had when the Rockets
hit I'm now having it right now I'm
convinced I'm gonna die I'm convinced
there's going to be another rocket
attack I'm convinced it's going to land
on me I'm convinced my parents are going
to find out I was here when the military
knocks on the door and tells them
and no logic can dissuade me
I know the one of the reasons I feel
this way is because I have no sense of
purpose right I didn't come here for any
reason I just came here to witness and
so I look I'm in the purpose business
I'm like all right Simon you need
purpose you need purpose come up with a
sense of purpose all right you're here
to learn and come back and tell their
story okay there you go and it made me
feel good for like five minutes and then
it disappeared in the panic and the
paranoia came back in and I went through
this cycle multiple times trying to
invent a purpose for myself
and then I finally realized I couldn't
come up with anything and I gave up
and I lie in that bed resigned to the
fact that I was stuck there without a
sense of purpose
and I decided that if I was going to get
stuck here
I would I might as well make myself
useful
that I would volunteer that I would
speak to the Troops that they wanted me
to I would carry boxes I would sweep
floors I didn't care how menial the work
I just wanted to serve those who are
serving others
and in that moment
I found unbelievable calm
even excitement
to be there to serve those who serve
others
as if it were a movie the timing was
extraordinary having just come to this
remarkable Insight the door flies open
it's major throck Morton he says there's
a flight that's been redirected it's
going to Ramstein we can get on the
plane if we leave now they're not going
to wait for us we have to go we have to
go now we have to go now where's Matt
I'm like he's at the gym we run to the
gym we get Matt off the treadmill
there's no time for him to shower he
puts his uniform back on we grab all of
our stuff and we run to the flight line
to get on this plane
we get to the flight Lane we can see the
C-17 we're supposed to get on it's right
over there we can see it but the
security stops us and won't let us onto
the flight line
there's a fallen soldier ceremony
happening somewhere on the base and out
of respect everything stops
and so we sat on the curb and waited and
while we were sitting there I told the
guys what I had gone through lying in
that bed mind you I have no idea how
long I was in that bed for I could have
been in there for 10 minutes I could
have been there for an hour I don't want
anybody to tell me either I had lost all
concept of time
I sat there and told them what I had
gone through and I'd come to this
remarkable Insight that true purpose in
life
is to serve those who serve others and I
wept and I wept while I was sitting on
that curb and one of the things that a
lot of people don't know about the
military is crying is just fine
finally the security came up and we were
able to walk to the aircraft we boarded
the plane we would be the only three
passengers aboard this aircraft what
what I didn't know at the time is the
reason this flight had been redirected
is that we would be carrying the soldier
for whom they just had the fallen
soldier ceremony
we stood there and waited and the Army
brought on the flag-draped casket
the soldiers put the casket right in the
middle of the aircraft they stood there
and did a very slow
eight count salute
they turned marched off the plane and we
could watch them hugging and crying as
they walked out of sight
our Air Force crew got to work and they
strapped the casket down in the middle
of the aircraft and we got going
I've never had such an honor in my life
having just gone through this
experience that I had on the ground
learning that true purpose is the
opportunity to serve those who serve
others
that I get to bring home somebody who
knows a lot more about purpose than I
ever will
we land at Ramstein
and we have one night at Ramstein before
we come home
the final flight home is another C-17
back to Andrews Air Force Base
and this is a an aeromedical evacuation
so it's um what they call an AE Mission
so wounded wound the wounded some
ambulatory some not
um and we get into the flight this
flight was a little more relaxed and you
know lots of nurses tending to the
wounded
and in the back of the aircraft was a
single
Gurney a single Marine who was in what
they call c-cat which is an artificial
coma
uh very very badly wounded and he had
four doctors attending to him personally
and I sort of avoided going to the back
of the plane because it was
uncomfortable
and I finally said no I gotta go so I
walked the back of the plane to talk to
the docks and they walked me through his
wounds um his buddy stepped on an IED
and was killed and he took the shrapnel
he had trapped on the chest shrapnel uh
in the eye
um and he was in very bad shape
and the docs were telling me that the
the amount of new uh techniques that
they were learning how to how to treat
trauma
just because of the war in Iraq and
Afghanistan was slowly making its way
into civilian hospitals so even when
they're wounded
they're still serving us
you know and the lead doc was a was a
was a reservist who works in an ER in
Austin
and had I not gone through what I had
just gone through 24 hours before I
would never have asked him this question
but I did I asked him hey Doc you are a
good guy you work in an ER you save
lives for a living that's your job do
you have a different kind of feeling on
these missions than you do back home
and he looked at me and he said
90 to 95 of the people who come through
an ER are either drunks or idiots
he says there's not a single drunker
idiot on this aircraft he said the
feeling that I get when I get to work
these missions during my Reserve hours
is more powerful than any feeling I ever
get when I'm working back home
again the greatest sense of purpose and
meaning we can have in our lives is to
serve those who serve others
part of the deal that they made with me
when I went the general said I want you
to go and I want you to come back and
tell us your insights what you saw that
we did well what you saw we just tell us
your insights so about two weeks after I
got home I went back to Scott Air Force
Base and was standing in a room full of
all the brass all the generals Colonels
all the command from Mobility forces and
they just wanted me to report on what I
saw and I went through everything and I
wasn't sure if I was going to tell them
about bringing home this flag drip
casket that was my the emotions were
very raw still and I'm not sure I wanted
to do it or could do it and I remembered
I was reporting on everything else that
I saw and the people I met and the
things that I thought were amazing
I took a pause and I decided to tell the
story and now the again the emotions are
right on the surface and I tell the
whole story in even more detail that I'm
telling you now
and I got to the point where I choked up
and I couldn't continue I couldn't tell
the story anymore
now if this was the private sector and I
was standing on a stage telling this
exact story somebody in private sector
would say to me take your time
they'd say
it's okay that's what they would say to
me right it's happened
take your time right
that's not what happened
I stood there completely choked up I
couldn't I couldn't speak and was one
voice from the back of the room the
general
and he said
go on
meaning go on and we're with you
right and that's the difference between
private sector and these wonderful
people in private sector they say to you
take your time as if you're alone
take all the time you need by yourself
and here these people who understand
what service truly means they say go
forwards go on move forwards you have no
choice and we will be with you
and that's what I learned from them when
my friends are struggling I don't say
take your time
when my friends are struggling I say go
on when my friends are crying I say go
on
the underlying message is and I am here
sitting in the mud with you
it is the greatest honor of my life and
because of that experience that's where
the book Leaders Eat Last came from
that experience was the impetus for that
book
so when we talk about what the future
looks like I just want to live a life of
service I want to continue to serve
those who serve others and to meet
people who live a life of service I will
do anything for them I think there's an
Unwritten rule that when you meet
someone who's devoted their life to
serving those who serve others that it
is our responsibility to serve them
there's an Unwritten rule the reason I
do so much pro bono stuff is because
when I meet people who are the on the
side of good on the side of service I
obey that Unwritten agreement that I
will be there for you and I will serve
you and expect nothing in return
and if you want to bring It full circle
back to relationships when one person
shows up in the relationship to serve
you
you have the moral responsibility to
serve them because to serve someone who
serves others they are serving you which
means we have to serve them
I live my life by that code
the key the key second second line in
true purpose is serving those that serve
others the line that you've added and
that you learn from your experience
going to Afghanistan was
that will be there with you along the
way
how important is that for you in your
mission that you have someone there with
you and do you feel like you have
someone there with you
on the mission you're on you talked
about the iceberg pulling it out of the
ocean at the start of this conversation
you reflected on feeling lonely not
understood
I feel lonely for personal it's my
personal life right
yeah do you feel like you have people
that are there with you absolutely and
when somebody comes up to me on the
street and says thank you you changed my
life I always say the same thing to them
thank you for being a part of the
movement
I always thank them for being a part of
the movement when they say your life
changed me
my word back to them is continue your
work right thank you for being a part of
the movement is what I always say
because when you say I I do not feel
alone I feel I feel that I'm a part of
an army with thousands to the left and
thousands to the right dare I say
Millions to the left and millions to the
right
some who I know and most I will never
know but we were all marching towards
the same direction to build this world
that we all believe in in our capacity
whether we're doing it for our little
company where we're doing it for our
family whether we're doing it for our
friends or whether we're doing it at
massive scale because we have that
opportunity because we have a bully
pulpit or we we lead a large
organization that's the professional
side yes
personally do I feel I have people to my
left and right to work with yes 100
percent
absolutely my team is incredible my
closest Confidant is my sister you know
my sister and I are business partners
and the best of friends
this question started with me asking you
about looking forward a couple of years
and everything's idyllic you've given me
the professional answer yeah the
personal side of that coin is kind of
what I'm trying to yeah understand I
mean I think the answer is I I want
somebody I I love companionship
and I want to be able to
more than talk about and share my
magical Surreal Life with someone
because I I have a I have a wonderful
life and I do want to share with
somebody I think sharing is more fun
than just telling people about something
you know I want to come back and be
remember that thing that we did as
opposed to can I tell you about this
thing that I did you know
um uh uh like
I and I wanna and I want to share
somebody else's life I want to hear
about their bad day I want to hear about
their good day I want to be their
cheerleader you know I I I want the
opportunity I've been a shitty servant
in my relationships in the past
I've been a really shitty servant and uh
and I've built the skill set
you know I'm a slow learner give me a
break better to learn it now than learn
it never
um but I want the opportunity to like
take all these skills that I've been
talking about really effectively and
really good at doing professionally and
I want the opportunity to do it just for
one person
if I mean
you spent your life um being a fantastic
servant
to me from before we even met to many
more people like me and you know this
you said millions to your left Millions
you're right yeah it's Millions you've
been a fantastic service to millions and
sometimes even in my own life I reflect
and think the service that I did whether
it was building the service to my
employees or the service to the outside
world it came at a cost and that was
often the service to one individual who
was right there who I sometimes took for
granted over and over again to the point
that I lost them and then had to live
with the regret
um
but I mean it just seems so obvious to
me that because you have the awareness
of all of that you're perfectly placed
to serve
D I'm having a thought an Insight right
now which I hadn't had before
which is we've talked about
you know everything that we gain in this
life comes at a cost and the only
question is was the cost worth it
and so now if you say I put all of this
focused on this movement and it came at
such personal cost right like I took my
eye off the ball I wasn't investing the
time to be a better boyfriend to learn
how to have relationship to learn how to
manage you know some of the symptoms of
the ADHD just to forget about the ADHD
just to learn not to be an idiot you
know
uh was it worth it
and the sad thing is it was
like
if you're asking me in the state that
I'm sitting in now would I sit in the
state right now again and do it all
exactly the same way
I'm not sure I do it exactly the same
way
but I believe the movement
that we're building and what you and I
are both a part of
it was worth it now it wouldn't have
been worth it if I didn't learn this
lesson now
and be given the opportunity now
you know would I preferred it five years
ago ten years ago yes
but uh
but I I believe the cost was worth it
because I think the work that we're
doing has an ability to it and it
matters
and that
that weirdly makes it sort of huh
that's really nice yeah the cost was
worth it
Simon thank you
do I have to pay for this
I think I think he's probably thinking
the same to be fair no I really I really
mean that I mean
I really mean that I really mean that
because it's it's so unbelievably
powerful
um
to have a conversation like this it's
it's these are the most important
conversations we have it's not like
information sharing and this trick about
this business and how to help this team
member the human level stuff which is
the foundation of all the things we do
our success our businesses whatever and
we struggle with the most but people
like me and you just don't talk about
because that's not what we're
we you know we're recruited to talk
about well then people don't ask us
those questions and sometimes if they do
we're you know we got good at avoiding
them and I think that the tragedy is is
that
you know
people are modeling their
their making choices based on what we're
saying and we're leaving out a huge part
of the human story
and
you know for us not to talk about this
stuff
does the people who are on their own
journey and using our information as
part of their education a disservice
um
so yeah I think this is a great lesson
all around and this is it you know
people often ask me why on the diversity
I spend so long talking about health
mental health mental Fitness mental
Fitness mental Fitness
um struggles and all of those things
because I think that's the subject
matter that is underserved so that's
pretty much the whole space that I play
in I spend very little time talking
about how to scale a company and all I
focus what I on what I believe is the
underserved foundations of being a great
successful quote-unquote individual yeah
which is all the stuff we've talked
about today yeah
hey thanks so much I I uh I really love
when we do this so do I and the thing is
the thing is I think what people don't
realize is you know you and I know each
other respect each other and like each
other but we don't go out for dinner
we've never actually gone out for a meal
you know and I think what's so
interesting is I think if we did this is
what we would talk about and so
you know what it's a bit it's better to
do it with others than than than just
buy ourselves at dinner we skipped the
first date we went they went straight
into the relationship we both hate the
first date so that's okay hey thank you
so much I really do appreciate it thank
you Simon
[Music]
quick one as you guys know we're lucky
enough to have blue jeans as a sponsor
and supporter of this podcast for anyone
that doesn't know blue jeans is an
online video conferencing tool that
allows you to have slick fast good
quality online meetings without any of
those glitches that you'd normally find
with other meeting online providers you
know the ones I'm talking about and they
have a new feature called Blue Jeans
basic which I wanted to tell you about
blue jeans basic is essentially a free
version of their top quality video
conferencing and that means that you get
immersive video experiences you get that
super high quality super easy and zero
fuss experience and apart from zero time
limits on meetings and calls it also
comes with High Fidelity audio and video
including Dolby voice they also have
expertise grade security so you can
collaborate with confidence it's so
smooth that it's quite literally changed
the game for myself and my team without
compromising quality at all so if you'd
like to check them out search
bluejeans.com and let me know how you
get on I have to say I've been on a bit
of a journey with this brand because
when I started my business in new
territories when we first moved social
chain to the to New York City the first
place we went to was wework we moved
four of our team members out to New York
City and we built the business from
there
um I have to say there's something
magical about weworks I've spent the
last two or three weeks in LA in a wee
work and as you walk in the front door
every day it's almost like that sense of
community that sense of magic excitement
camaraderie is tangible and you don't
get that when you're working at home you
don't get that often when you're sat in
your bed on your laptop there's
something about getting out and getting
into a wee work that makes me feel a
sense of Entrepreneurship and and
creativity and building and the way that
we work to design both both in the way
that they offer subscriptions so that
you can work you know on demand but also
the the flexibility of the contracts
means that it's just the perfect place
for businesses to scale their companies
and if you haven't checked out where you
work and you want to you can go to
we.co CEO and there you can get 50 off a
trial Day At wework Close to You
[Music]
oh